oui bienvenue parole autochtone si c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine
encore une fois loin des studios mais
proche des médias sociaux où je me suis
inspiré pour ma chronique cette semaine
et ce qui m'a inspiré
c'est les masques faciaux qu'on utilise
pour se protéger contre le coc u19 et
pour d'autres maladies bien sûr mais
c'est surtout la forme d'adaptation ou
d'adoption culturel qu'il utilisait pour
transformer ces masques là et les
adapter à notre culture en tant que
première nation
pourquoi je dis ça c'est que j'en ai vu
énormément soit fait en cuir d'orignal
fumée avec du tout stage fait de poils
d'orignal j'en ai vu aussi en panier de
fresnes avec du foin d'odeur et ce qui
m'a particulièrement inspiré c'est que
j'ai vu mon ami allende à en faire un
avec 2 les corses de boulot et ce qui
est amusant c'est que le patron utilisé
pour faire les masques de face et bien
ressemble énormément au devant d'un
canot donc toute la forme de son masque
ressembler à un canot d'écorcé de
bouleau bien sûr à l'intérieur elle met
des filtres parce qu'on s'entend que
respirer à travers 2 les corses de
boulot c'est pas exactement ce qui est
plus efficace contre le coc vide
cependant ça m'a fait penser beaucoup
comment à travers les siècles depuis le
début de colonisation les premières
nations ont adapté ou adopter certains
matériaux d'équité venue de l'europe
pour en faire des objets traditionnels
ou quand je t'ai objet culturel
autochtone j'ai amené deux exemples j'ai
embauché et j'ai des cornes de jean gol
dresse le hochet il est inspiré d auch
et de courage qui était utilisé l'ordre
des médecis mais imaginez que vous êtes
un soldat lors de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
loin de chez vous prie en europe et que
la conche que vous utilisez pour faire
cette saison chez les postes disponibles
donc on utilisait les rations de l'armée
c'est à dire les salières et les balles
de fusil pour pouvoir en faire des
hochets donc on pourrait se servir pour
faire de la musique et bien sûr pouvoir
demander le support de nos ancêtres y
avait énormément
c'est le type spirituel et je pense
extrêmement ce que le gic du support de
savoir qu'on n'est pas trop loin qu'on
est très loin de sa nation et les
rochers et les les petites cloches elle
par exemple était fait avec le dessus
des couvercles des petites cannes de
tabac et comme le tabac est une herbe
médicinale reconnue et bien c'était une
manière de dire que c'était de la
médecine par adaptation donc pour faire
les petites cloches il faut quand même
utilisé beaucoup de cannes de tabac je
peux vous le dire
alors vous pouvez voir comment c'était
une manière d'adopter et d'adapter des
matériaux qui n'était pas
traditionnellement les nôtres bien sûr
ce ne sont pas les laisser manière qu'on
a eus d'adapter ou d'adopter mais vous
pouvez voir que c'est des objets qui ont
été utilisés pour le bien-être soit
physique ou psychologique des personnes
qui les utilisaient alors vous imaginez
qu'avant un masque qui est adapté à
votre culture permet non seulement de
montrer la fierté la résilience une
nation mais aussi comment on peut
demander l'apport des ancêtres dernière
nous quand on est très spirituel donc
juste pour vous dire je me suis fait un
masque et j'ai utilisé ce que nous en 6
on appelle le coup comme scorff ou le
foulard de grand-maman sa flore qui
n'est pas du tout des premières nations
a inspiré beaucoup des fleurs qu'on peut
voir en roumanie ou en russie et je m'en
suis fait un masque pour justement
pouvoir avoir cette fierté
cependant si je peux finir avec une note
quand vous fabriquer vous même vos
masques bien sûr utilisé trois
épaisseurs de tissu c'est ce qui est
recommandé pour vraiment bloqué les
microbes qui rend l'histoire mais aussi
pensé bien où vous allez mettre le motif
de votre masque parce que vous pourriez
bien vous retrouver à voir des choses
qui apparaissent tels que deux grosses
narines roots
alors n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
idées pour des futurs chronique et
c'était pas non plus si vous avez des
commentaires
et surtout ce qui serait intéressant
partager dans les commentaires les
masques que vous avez pu voir qu'ils
sont inspirés de l'écriture des
premières nations
alors je souhaite une belle semaine